é
boa tarde
vou falar um pouco sobre o que é um
pouco de carreiras improváveis carreiras
na criativas um pouco do nosso caso é só
para saber um pouquinho assim a gente
tem uma platéia realmente não conheço
ninguém
acho que as pessoas todos que indiquei
para se inscreverem todas são
selecionadas
eu queria saber assim a gente vê que tem
o pessoal da engenharia é bastante
engenharia
temos designers é óbvio que temos aqui é
jogadas as pessoas de direito nós temos
músicos mas se você trabalha com que a
música mesmo
bem essa é uma pergunta a que eu escutei
a minha vida inteira eu não sei direito
porquê mas parente amigo pessoas
conhecidas sempre insistem é que você
faz
eu sou músico e trabalha com que essa é
uma máxima e é exatamente um pouco por
causa disso o título da da minha fala é
mas no final é isso eu sou né o baixista
da banda móveis coloniais de acaju não
está funcionando
é nessa hora mudava para uma escola e
não sei talvez também porque mesmo
professor de sociologia com formação em
antropologia que seis meses antes de
fazer a inscrição no vestibular
pensava em fazer engenharia então talvez
um pouco por isso as pessoas me pergunta
é por que eu faço com a música mas todo
mundo conhece que haja uma banda com
nove pessoas um som esquisito um nome
mais estranho ainda ou seja uma banda
fadado ao fracasso
e essa ea dessa dessa noção de que
estávamos parados no fracasso que eu
falo nem um pouco algumas experiências
que a gente teve a gente num
participando de uma rodada de negócio é
um festival em goiânia
a gente foi pra cima de uma rodada de
pit e tinha várias pessoas do mundo
inteiro assim
produtores selos gravadoras agências
book é galera de jogos eletrônicos
estava sem te todo mundo é realmente uma
galera muito fera ea gente preparou todo
material super de tático assim um vídeo
release e outro dinâmico porque tinha
pouco tempo ea gente que passa tudo vai
lá números é público atingido estava lá
a coisa toda não chega às conquistas
vamos a todas nossas conquistas e aí a
gente começou então a nossa passamos o
vídeo e começamos a nossa fala lá nós
somos móveis coloniais de acaju banda de
brasília com 10 pessoas na mesma hora o
cara na frente era do principal da
principal agência de boquim de bandas
independentes dos estados unidos
margot caneta balançam a cabeça a gente
viu ali que o número de pessoas e é
muito maior um problema muito maior do
que as nossas conquistas que a gente
tinha
ficamos com isso já estava me
acostumando com isso no ano seguinte a
gente voltou para o mesmo festival
pela mesma rodada de negócio ea gente
tem um objetivo muito específico
a gente queria tocar num festival na
bélgica que chamava porque o pop que
estava um cara o governador estava lá e
ele e levar uma banda do brasil para
tocar no festival
ele estava em goiânia no futebol só tem
tantas bandas ea gente muito esperto a
gente começou a falar ele vai chegar em
brasília precisa de alguém para lá em
goiânia
vamos oferecer um produto chove pode com
gente pega ainda no nosso ônibus até
pega ele antes ele é arquiteto
a gente dá uma volta nossa brasília e
talvez as coisas toda a gente vai com
ele pra pra goiânia
aí beleza fizemos isso o tecladista
ficou de fazer se mexer e tal é já tinha
três pessoas em goiânia participando das
outras rodadas de negócios a um outro
pessoal montando um ônibus com o
equipamento está aquela coisa toda tá
olhando a gente vai ter um aqui me fala
tem outros londres chegou em goiânia a
gente vai participar da rodada de
negócios mostramos todos nossos números
lá incríveis tal e aí o cara que massa
mas quando sua seleção a última pergunta
somos dez lra é pô não dá não dá a gente
não
apesar de ser um grande palco
eu não tenho verba tem como a gente mas
eu queria agradecer muito vocês terem
recebido terem acolhido mostrar a cidade
tal que eu posso eu puder fazer eu faço
indica que ela vai fazer a gente só quer
que você assistir o show hoje à noite é
o último show só pode ser que esteja
meio cansado mas fechou vai só isso aí
beleza aí jogou no camarim na galera tem
que ser o melhor show da vida de uma vez
até agora não é nem importa tem que ser
em subir no palco e ele realmente fez um
dos melhores shows até então do móveis
um impactante 3 mil pessoas pulando lá
no centro os animais são paulo hoje para
goiânia
foi incrível
vou tocar marítimo fora que nem lembrava
mais porque estava pra que ela assim e
tal
ele veio correndo em khyber que show
incrível ano que vem vocês um pouco o
bope não quero nem saber ano que vem
vocês estão a gente dá um jeito a gente
resolve o problema das passagens mas eu
quero esse show lá no pukkelpop o champô
porque o pop foi incrível a foi a mesma
relação e energia que a gente consegue
em brasília só que sem a língua mas em
troca da linguagem
mas foi incrível também mas é isso não
há o número de pessoas sempre foi um
problema desde o início a gente atrás de
show ela chegava a produtora sempre
assim o produtor da gente o palco é um
tipo 2 e meio por 26 cabem três pessoas
quatro no máximo sexta 19 não tem
problema ficar 14 em cima do palco 5
ficou embaixo nos dá um jeito bom mas só
tem três microfones vocês 16 microfones
não tem problema sobre dividir a pista
com os três juntos aqui vou fazer aqui
junto com o outro a gente dá um jeito
você tem que montar e desmontar em 15
minutos a gente faz em 13 pode ficar
tranquilo a gente sabia que a gente
tinha que funcionar como uma banda de 34
pessoas
a gente tinha que fazer ser viável como
uma banda de 34 pessoas
mas o show não show num o show tinha que
valer como a banda de três pessoas
o disco 3 bandas e agora vim aqui eles
não votava aí
a gente quer equivaler a três bandas de
impacto da explosão de fazer a diferença
naquele jogo mas também não só de
problemas a gente também teve muita
sorte
e como diz um amigo meu sorte é um
exercício
a gente ganhou um vôo que pareça que tem
uma companhia fazendo a promoção e de
uma televisão de 40 polegadas para cada
um dos passos dos passageiros né
ela nos 12 o road não foi menos 13 tvs
de uma [ __ ] sorte né
como é que você coloca 13 é 12 pessoas
motoristas todo o equipamento e três tvs
dentro de uma van a gente só tinha uma
van mas a gente dá sempre jeito não tem
a gente dá um jeito você tem a sua
realidade você vai ter que dar um jeito
é em 2003 a 2008 a 2009 na verdade a
gente a gente consolidou essa formação e
essa estrutura de dinâmica de trabalho
que era essa esse trabalho coletivo de
11 páginas neve início da banda das
pessoas marcar ensaio não existir
whatsapp aquela cena orelhão ligar nem
gay nem tinha celular nem nada e meio a
gente sempre foi muito legal a gente
desde o início tem que se organizar para
fazer funcionar a conexão entre nove e
dez pessoas diferentes interesses
diferentes histórias diferentes né em
2008 a gente consultoria tal ea gente
abrir uma empresa na animal escolaridade
caju produções artísticas que não era o
início de um novo modelo mas sem a
consolidação de um modelo que a gente
vinha desde o início trabalhando que o
modelo que a gente chama né de banda
empresa é com a gente e evitado
entrevistas palestras é esse modelo não
significa que é uma banda que tenha uma
empresa uma empresa que gerencia uma
banda não essa ideia por trás desse
modelo é exatamente uma banda empresa é
uma unidade é um unidade de um
empreendimento de um grupo de pessoas
que da mesma maneira como vai pensar
dentro do
studio as suas músicas só criação
artística pensando de forma
empreendedora pensando como ela atinge o
público qual o melhor horário para você
publicar uma música como funciona as
redes sociais onde está seu público como
você pode alcançar
como você pode criar ações de
engajamento deste público as suas
dificuldades e como que aquela sua
música artisticamente pode influenciar
nisso pode ela realizar aquilo mas da
mesma maneira
do outro lado do estúdio no escritório
ela tem que pensar a sua ação
empreendedora sua ação empresarial de
forma artística de forma criadora
ela não pode agir trabalho e economia
criativa e reproduzir o que existe já no
mercado estabelecido como esse é o
padrão isso é o certo
isso vai não funciona a gente tem que
inovar a gente tem que necessariamente
pensar nossa ação de forma
artisticamente falando né tem que inovar
nesse aspecto é esse modelo a gente
realmente ficou conhecido por isso tal
várias bandas vêm atrás da gente queria
um pouco como é que faz para montar esse
modelo é fácil a gente se implementar
isso na minha banda e tal e uma proposta
de receptivo era expandir nosso o
conhecimento que a gente adquire a nossa
experiência é só que a gente vivia em
vários testes ea banda a gente é um
produtor e membro da banda a gente ver
bandas chamando alguém para sair da
banda porque seu produtor da banda igual
nosso tal e aí o que a gente percebeu é
que não faz sentido isso
da mesma maneira como a gente queria
quando a gente queria implementar um
sistema de fluxo de caixa controle e
gestão já gaiola comuns a uma
multinacional o automobilístico faz a
gente não dava certo a gente
implementando esse modelo para outras
bandas não dava certo porque no fundo a
questão
a questão é que o modelo não não é o que
deve ser empregado o que deve ser
implementado discutido no senado a idéia
não é à toa que a gente está aqui ea
idéia por trás da banda empresa é aquela
que eu falei você consegue trabalhar os
dois lados com uma mescla entre as duas
ea gente ficou pensando ah então como é
que há gente no nosso caso era como é
que se pode então espalhar essas idéias
se não só através
modelos modelo não funciona em que
disseminar as idéias como é que a gente
pode fazer isso né ea gente questionava
vital até que tivemos a ideia mas nessa
foto é e aí a gente começou a perceber
que quem teria que trabalhar diretamente
com as bandas não para implementar uma
forma de ação mas né como uma dinâmica
de construir junto com eles é uma parte
de uma hora está a gente criou a agência
circula que há uma agência que presta
serviço para as bandas uma incubadora e
que não tenta implementar modelos para
elas mas sim é construir a partir das
idéias modelos específicos para cada uma
delas
ou seja quais são as idéias que a banda
onde a banda até chegar onde ela está
vindo onde ela está e onde ela ia chegar
então o que a gente pode estruturar para
isso a gente faz isso em várias áreas
a gente em um ano de projeto atendeu
mais 150 bandas que os nossos serviços
sejam pontuais sejam eles de longo prazo
estivemos envolvidos de diversas
maneiras como produção produção
executiva execução agenciamento tal mas
120 shows ea gente gerou até agora é em
ações
o valor de mercado dessas ações e
equivale a mais de 860 mil reais dos
nossos serviços e aí é é uma coisa que
eu sempre falo para as bandas sim é você
tem que ter é essa quebra da busca pelo
modelo é bem difícil é muito difícil
você fala pra uma pessoa olha você vai
seguir aqui acho que muita gente estava
ótimo vai entrar no curso o curso vai
ser feriado vou fazer mesmo turma e tal
pegar essas matérias é que vou fazer
quando me formar eu sei qual é a
carreira que eu vou seguir o que a gente
pode ter tanta certeza assim é então o
que a gente sempre fala isso remix
remodele takei rodas ideia dos outros se
transformou nelas delas nas suas idéias
pensando como você pode
como onde você está inserido e como você
pode colocar aquilo pra dentro de você
como que aquilo vai impactar sua vida ea
vida das outras pessoas quem são as
pessoas que estão com conectadas ali que
elas fazem como elas podem qual exemplo
delas que podem puxar pra você e tal
adaptar modelos de outras de outros
contextos é sempre interessante mas não
os modelos as idéias é não não é então
assim quando eu falo de carreira na
carreira musical é possível é possível é
muito difícil talvez você não é ser
músico talvez não é ser músico só com a
mesma banda de jazz e música de várias
bandas
talvez vai trabalhar com produção 13
road talvez você vai ser lá gravar
existem várias maneiras de trabalhar na
música
se a sua idéia é trabalhar a música você
vai poder fazer isso isso se aplica a
qualquer outra carreira
e aí falando da universidade é eu acho
que é uma coisa bem importante sim o
papel da universidade não é gerar uma
profissão é gerar a formação
as pessoas deveriam entrar na
universidade querendo buscar a sua
formação enquanto seres humanos enquanto
conhecimento claro conhecimento
específicos talvez mas nunca quanto à
profissão a pessoa a gente deveria
encontrar depois de falar isso em
carreira em brasília é uma coisa é de
outro mundo
bem eu era concursado professor da
secretaria de educação e eu pedi
exoneração na palavra mais temida por
todos brasilienses incrível pra seguir
essa minha carreira
pode ser que não dê certo pelo menos eu
posso trabalhar de bermuda isso pra mim
não tem obrigado